what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where I give my
thoughts over morning coffee today I
don't have coffee but I do have a cucha
so you know let me know your favorite
morning drink in the comments um an
interesting thing I've been doing this
week I've been trying to get more
carnivore and I've been eating like
three steaks a
day and guys I'm starting to see what
the carnivore people are are
saying yeah I've
been you feel a lot more energized and
I'm not even really changing what I eat
I'm just eating more steak right now
we'll see we'll see if I stick to this
I'm not going to sell dreams
anyways um so today I wanted to talk
about how
um really when I started the channel I
was really focused on like what is
true and really the channel sort of
started when I had I would watch like
myin I would watch Kevin Samuel was was
probably like the number one influence
on me when it came to starting the
channel um I would watch all these
different like red pill content creators
and I thought they just started such
interesting conversation so I would sort
of bring the ideas to the girls that
were on my volleyball team and I would
red pill them so like there's a girl on
my team her name was Jess and I would
bring her and then I would show her
these videos and I would ask her what
she thought
um
and sometimes I realized and it's really
hard not to do this that in the pursuit
of like truth like I I feel like the
truth there's like so much anger around
it because I I honestly think the closer
I get to the truth the more I get these
like personal crazy like attacks where
they just attack me attack me attack me
um so when I had this like video I did
last year with Nick
Fuentes and when I brought Nick Fuentes
on I actually I get like nervous saying
his name because there's just such like
a visceral reaction to him but I always
have to remind
myself that I'm speaking what I know to
be true and my experience and I can't
help people's reactions so there was
like this um clip that went super viral
of me talking about you know and the way
they would phrase it is Pearl said that
slavery was embellished that's like the
way they would put
it and even talking about this I get
very like anxious like I'm like oh God
please don't come for me but whatever
and really what I was trying to be
honest about at the time was how people
use atrocities to like control people so
if you say anything about slavery if you
question any of the facts that you see
on TV or from historians they they
immediately call you racist and all this
stuff and then cancel you they do the
same thing with the Holocaust right if
you say anything about it then boom all
these people will come out and call you
anti-semitic they do the same thing with
women's issues if I say and and I get
away with it because I'm a woman but if
I was a man and a man came forward and
said oh um women didn't want the right
to vote or whatever they would call him
a sexist and they just it's like a
system and when I started to figure out
this system for all these different
issues wasn't just slavery um I got this
like heated like like ah and I've almost
gotten to the point where I you know
guys I'm not even a flat
earther but sometimes I think the flat
earthers might be right only because of
this visceral
reaction like to exploring the topic
like people get so angry if you just
explore it and say well maybe the Earth
is
flat then they get so angry when it's
like what why are we getting angry about
these ideas let's let's explore it I'm
not even saying I'm not even saying it
was but I'm like I mean the moon landing
does look really fake I mean you know um
so in the spring basically all these
people that I thought and I'm
not saying this to feel bad for myself
or anything cuz I have a great life but
this is what happened this clip goes
viral all of these people I thought were
my friends like I literally thought like
I was friends with start turning on me
and these are people that I've known for
years and and now they're calling me
Colin like people I think think I I
think I'm friends with you know um
saying these like you know terrible
things about me it and this made me sort
of like get a little bitter towards
London you know and I was just like I
just wanted to go home I wanted to say
screw it I want to be out of this
country and I wanted to you know go to
my dad and just like go home whatever
um
and I regret letting all of that like
affect me because I just didn't expect
people that knew me in real life to do
that um so I really regret not
appreciating London because I'm part
British now I'm not a ton British but I
just it's really interesting I've been
learning more about like my family's
history and my family I guess got here
on one side 10 years after the Mayflower
how cool is that right that's pretty
cool or in the US but basic basically at
one point someone in my family came from
Britain and the cool thing about England
which I've been starting to appreciate
is they just have like these old
buildings like these old and like it's
almost like Divine some of the buildings
here like they are
like inspired by God and I've almost
started to think that
maybe America wasn't this like Christian
Nation that we thought and maybe America
like actually was
ungodly and I know this this idea kind
of makes me sad because growing up
there's all this like patriotism like I
grew up in rural um rural Illinois like
an hour from Chicago I mean not rural
rural but like my my mom's family is
from like rural rural super out in the
middle of nowhere Wisconsin so I grew up
around people that were really Pat
patriotic and really like um just
America and like it's a Christian Nation
whatever but I started to think that
maybe the natural order of the world
okay and I've been playing around with
this idea so don't quote me on this but
it goes God men women
children in
America the
government is separated from
God and maybe the government is actually
meant to go here it's supposed to go God
government men women children and I had
this thought when I found out that the
US actually LED in divorce even when it
was just the
colonies um and the British were like
appalled by the S sorts of like Sodom
andary however you say that stuff that
was going on in the
colonies so
okay I'm I'm like putting two and two
together when capitalism which I grew up
always thinking that was amazing and
awesome okay I always just thought
capitalism the market corrects itself
and I'm not saying it's not I I think
that you shouldn't have a bunch of
government
regulation and I don't again I'm just
playing with ideas so please do not
quote me and clip me and
whatever but when you put money
capitalism basically puts money at the
top of
everything and when you do that my
thought is I I think it's almost a
disservice and that's when you like when
I look at all of the that's wrong
with society today I don't know if I
believe in these like evil Elites that
were like had this grand plan to ruin
the country or the world or whatever I
almost think they just thought we would
make more money if we did this I'll give
you an example
transgenderism you know that stuff
they're M they're basically mutilating
autistic people it's mostly women in
that movement I just saw a video someone
was saying it's more men turning into
women it's not it's more women turning
into men um and it's usually autistic
children that like find this and think
it's a solution like basically the
transgender movement puts the solutions
to a normal autistic kid's Pro a normal
autistic girls problems as
transgenderism like the lack of friends
connection you know feel like fitting in
whatever and really I don't think these
doctors
thought went in thinking we want to
destroy people I think they just thought
I can make a good chunk of
change doing this and if we had a
government that was God and the
government were intertwined there was no
separation
of of like State and religion they would
just outright banish things and I almost
think the problem
when the us became a money first country
is that then the governments that were
God first could not compete because in
that example they're going to make more
money doing that um they they won't not
make an atomic bomb because there's
money at the end of
it and I I've almost started to think
take it with a grain of salt that maybe
God and government are meant to be
intertwined and capitalism might
actually not be the good thing that we
thought it
was
um
so it's given me like a new appreciation
for London because you almost see things
that are inspired by God where the
cities in the US are just it's it's very
like Bland for the most part um you
don't really see the like beauty that
you see here in some of the buildings
especially like you know like where the
Palaces all that stuff
um all right so the next thing I wanted
to talk
about cuz I do bring up
God I wanted to tell you guys about my
Faith right what is Pearl's religion
what is Pearl's
faith and I think there's like a lot of
confusion on the internet
because I've always felt weird about
being overly preachy in public about my
faith now I know I know all of the
Christians will come
in and say pearl but the Bible
says the Bible says you need to be super
public and preach
now I don't have any Bible scriptures to
back this up so do not do not come
saying Pearl doesn't know but sometimes
I just follow things that make sense to
me and I find out they're biblical
later to me we have the natural order of
the world right and weaker men are
supposed to submit to Stronger men so I
almost think it's supposed to go and I
guess this didn't really happen for me
because my my my dad is Catholic but
he's not like the most religious guy on
the planet but I would think in an ideal
family it would
go the dad submits to the government and
like works or whatever and it's funny
cuz my dad isn't the most religious
person but he actually lives in a more
religious way than like any religious
people I know like doesn't drink Works
super hard like super kind heart like it
it's funny because I almost think think
there's men like my dad out there that
would be religious if there wasn't so
much in the church cuz like my
dad can't really articulate it in the
same way I couldn't articulate it when I
was younger and stuff bothered me but
like men are just naturally logical and
if they start getting these like weird
pastors and Priests that are just
like emotional and preaching that
doesn't make sense they'll just
naturally kind of leave anyways but I
would think the natural order of the
world is in like religion is the dad is
supposed
to seek follow God and seek truth right
and he's supposed to submit to Stronger
men and he's supposed to learn like we
should have a bunch of Scholars out
there and I'm sure we do but they're not
as like common as I would imagine they
would have been like a 100 200 years ago
that have dedicated their life to
seeking what is true and finding the
truth out about the Bible okay
imagine those men teach all of the other
men and the men in their families like
they teach their their daughters and
that's kind of the way like the ideal
way it should
go and I almost look at it like somebody
that starts preaching too soon does more
harm than
good the same way like um a personal
trainer um or Diet
nutritionist that doesn't really do
their due diligence you know now people
are doing carnivore and I'm I'm sort of
trying to dabble in that I'm not going
to say I'm in it but and they're finding
out that was true and growing up we
heard that you're supposed to eat the
most carbs and all of the personal
trainers that told people to do the food
triangle with all the
carbs LED more people to obesity rather
than Fitness because they were teaching
the wrong thing and I would never want
to be in a
position
where I am doing more harm than good
because I I am not 100% sure with what
is true and what isn't
true so a couple of years ago I really
wanted to figure out like what what was
true and um I wrote I remember a couple
of years ago I wrote down all the
religions cuz I was like what religion
am I and I wanted to know and at the
time I wrote down Christian Muslim
Catholic
Buddhist uh Christian Muslim Catholic
Buddhist and um Jud Jewish
Jewish and I actually remember wanting
to be Jewish because I'm a natural
skeptic and then I didn't have to
believe in the Miracles um I found out
later that was wrong because there's
miracles in the Old
Testament um but you know I I but I
remember reading about like what it took
to be Jewish and it it was really
difficult to convert and I
thought it's like a lot of
work when really it's like a one out of
five chance into oh I put Catholic too
sorry guys
but okay
so I I kind of just thought and then it
was like through the bloodline and I'm
like I don't even think I can become
Jewish anyway so I just sort of I just
sort of exed that one off and I also
exed it off because it didn't make sense
to me that Jesus was not God it it
didn't make sense to me and the reason
it didn't make sense to me was
because I felt
like if this guy was so well known a
thousand years later and he came
before like like it just didn't make
sense that we built all of this stuff
off of this guy that was not
God
now this could be flawed thinking but
this is what this is
why now I basically at the time I saw a
lot of what was probably more Western
propaganda and it made me more rule out
like the Muslim countries because my
thought was like at the time you know I
was more of like capitalist I thought
the West was like godsend I thought the
West was like amazing and so I ruled out
the Muslim and Buddhism
because I just felt like the countries
that seemed to follow God had more
Prosperity that sort of made sense to me
the time not saying this was the right
train of thought this is just what I was
thinking so it left me with Catholicism
and
Christianity and at the time I actually
picked
Christianity um and I I went to a
Christian Church for like two three
years and I was super involved in it I
lived with like um a Christian family
and I I really have like they they're
honestly a phenomenal Church um
but
I still noticed some I didn't know it
was feminism at the time but there like
the men were not masculine in that
church
um
and there is just something that felt
like off that's the only way I could put
it
um and I kept having the question come
back to my mind which is how do we know
what is true and what isn't true and to
me it does not make sense to have every
person just read the Bible and decide
for themselves the reason being um
that I I mean there's some gross
misinterpretations of the Bible that are
absolute and and start wars so
that's what led me to ca Catholicism to
to
basically stay Catholic was because
um I mean I'm a little biased I grew up
Catholic but
because it made more sense to have an
institution of and at the time I didn't
really think about the natural order of
the world like none of this was in my
head but it made more sense to have like
an
institution and to this day that still
makes the problem is institutions do get
corrupt and it's hard to not question
your faith as a Catholic when the pope
is who the pope is I I mean I mean we
can't look at this and not say that's
immoral my grandma would be rolling in
her grave right now
um
so
now I still think the institution makes
the most sense and having a group of the
like most wise well-
read and like competent men that come
together um but I question how an
institution Guided by God could get this
corrupt
um so that's kind of where I
am in I guess my like Faith
journey
and so and I guess the reason I Don't
Preach or I don't make it public is like
which it is public but not like crazy
public it's two reasons I almost think
that people that do that without a
fundamental understanding and knowledge
of everything they
believe it's almost to glorify
themselves more than God because I would
think that the the step to to converting
people is no your faith
first so know your faith so what do you
believe why do you believe it
two stop
sinning
plus live super
holy and then
three preach which I don't even really
think women should preach so I don't
know if I ever will but okay know your
faith so and when I think of this in
terms of like
Paul I know he had like God come down
and like he stopped he he first had to
realize he was a believer beli ver and
then he knew that he had Faith stops he
had to stopped sinning and then lived
super
holy and then he preached and converted
a bunch of people
so and I think that's why when we see
these influencers do these like
overnight I was a porn
star and now I'm a practicing
Catholic you almost don't believe it
because real change takes time um now
now when I was in college I I
was I I drank a lot a lot not not like a
ton but I was more of a a drinker you
know the last like two years
and really to break that habit I had to
get away from all that stuff and not now
it's like it doesn't even bother me like
I don't I don't care like it I I could
have a bunch of alcohol here I can have
a glass of wine from time to time I'm
not going to get super messed up like
it's totally fine um but like I think
about how hard it was to break that
habit now I'm trying to quit coffee and
oh my God you guys have seen my morning
coffee thoughts for two years of me
saying I'm addicted to Sugar I'm
addicted to coffee
and you've seen how unsuccessful and how
hard it has been to change and I think
when you have this super degenerate
lifestyle
when the idea that you can just change
overnight it's not the most believable
thing I I I think when people really do
change it's actually really difficult
and it's more difficult the longer
you've done it so I really only drank
for like I don't know 2 three
years and that was pretty hard to quit
imagine doing something for 10 and 15
and I remember having the thought that I
should get a hold of this habit
because people that do it for like 10
years they they I mean how do you think
we have all these alcoholic mothers you
know what I mean
um
so yeah so that's why I
don't go out and start preaching because
I really think I have to figure out what
I believe and why I believe it Catholic
makes the most sense to me but I still
have
questions um and you know it it's not
like I live a super crazy lifestyle but
I but I think I have things I should
work on I'm super
impatient um I get agitated kind of
easily
and you know I I
think I think I almost think that stuff
comes first before you start
preaching because otherwise to the same
way the personal trainer can lead more
people to destruction if they're not if
they don't know the right things I
almost feel the same way about religion
anyways um these are just my thoughts
today these thoughts could change over
time
um I I don't act like I have all the
answers but let me know what you guys
think in the comments like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time